it's a very british parliament building
but stormont has an irish nationalist
first minister elect michelle o'neill
wants the democratic unionists to accept
her political mandate as democrats the
dup but also the british government must
accept and respect the democratic
outcome of this election
brinkmanship will not be tolerated where
the north of ireland becomes collateral
damage in a game of chicken with the
european commission
the dup is boycotting power sharing over
the border in the irish sea the party
says shin feins demand that it takes its
seats is hypocritical
sinn fein at every general election seek
a mandate not to take their seats at
westminster and they don't take their
seats at westminster and no one
blames them
people the other political parties don't
point the finger at them because they
say we have a mandate well i have a
mandate to avoid a hard border between
northern ireland and the republic the uk
and eu agreed to an irish sea border but
the uk government's threat to tear up
the brexit protocol isn't going down
well with the middle ground ultimately
this is boris johnson's baby the
protocol was birthed on his watch
there's no point in telling us now it's
a disaster it's up to him to provide
solutions and those solutions have to be
agreed with the european union owen
tennyson wasn't born at the time of the
good friday agreement the youngest
member of the new assembly he longs for
better politics here i saw vetoes that
were designed to protect the rights of
minorities within northern ireland as
part of the good friday agreement being
turned on their head and abused to deny
lgbt people the right to marry the
person that they love and i think that
was the first time that i actually saw
that politics actually affected my life
very directly we're not just an orange
and green society despite how
represented we're actually a rainbow
society with much more diversity than
that brexit and the resulting sea border
have raised old questions
but new faces on the political stage are
generating hope
david blevins sky news at stormont